we are back with our live audience
tonight in studio Lindsey Graham Tommy
Lauren Dagan McDowell kellyanne Conway
Judge Jeanine Pirro right here on Set uh
but first a dire warning from a former
FBI special agent listen to this the FBI
will crush you the government will crush
you and your family if you try to expose
the truth about their wrongdoing now
make no mistake there is serious
misconduct going on at this FBI some now
believe that America's once Premier law
enforcement agency is now Beyond repair
especially the blatantly partisan
Washington field office which seemingly
operates as an arm of the democratic
party so let us be clear this isn't just
about the bureau's anti-trump Witch Hunt
called Crossfire hurricane which we have
gone into great detail this week the
political rot extends far beyond the
former president of the United States
you have pro-abortion activists
traditional no Catholics people moms and
dads who merely attend a trump rally
even angry parents how dare they speak
out about age appropriate material being
taught their kids or CRT how about we
stick to Reading Writing Math Science
and computers but if they speak out at a
school board meeting guess what you
speak out against critical race Theory
you can be scrutinized by your
weaponized FBI simply because of your
beliefs all of course while Hunter Biden
and Company they can apparently based on
his own laptop get away with pretty much
everything and anything zero
consequences now in a moment tonight
John Solomon will join us is a breaking
news story information on the FBI's
decision to obtain Financial records
from Americans without any legal process
at all whatsoever no warrant no subpoena
nothing now those targeted committed no
crimes they merely travel to Washington
D.C on or around January six to attend
former president Trump's speech now this
is egregious it's an abuse of power but
those that dare call it out from inside
the FBI they are brutally punished just
listen to today's testimony from three
former agents look at this they see what
becomes of whistleblowers how the FBI
destroys their careers suspends them
under false pretenses takes their
security clearances and pay with no true
options for real recourse or remedy this
is by Design
it creates an orwellian atmosphere that
silences opposition and discussion the
FBI weaponized the security clearance
processes to facilitate my removal from
active duty within one month of my
disclosures
in addition to an indefinite unpaid
suspension the FBI initiated a campaign
of humiliation and intimidation to
punish and pressure me to resign
in violation of HIPAA individuals at the
FBI leaked my private medical
information to a reporter at the New
York Times I was retaliated against
because I forwarded information in my
superiors and others that questioned the
official Narrative of the events of
January 6. as a result I was accused of
promoting conspiratorial views and
unreliable information I'm hopeful
scrutiny from Congress and from the
Inspector General will deter the FBI
from abusing the security clearance
process to retaliate against others the
way it's retaliated against me all right
now one of the whistleblowers that you
just heard from Marcus Allen had this to
say about the director of the FBI Ray
and January 6. take a look at this and
Mr Allen is it your belief that you were
retaliated against because you shared an
email that questioned the truthfulness
of FBI director Christopher Wray
yes sir and you believed that he wasn't
truthful based on testimony he'd given
to the United States Senate isn't that
right yes sir and in that testimony to
the Senate you believe that Christopher
Wray indicated that there were no
confidential informants and no uh FBI
assets that were present at the Capitol
on January 6th that were part of the
violent Riot isn't that right yes sir
all right now Marcus Allen's attorney
will join us in just a moment but here's
the truth January 6 we now know could
have been prevented according to the
federal January 6 investigators quote
law enforcement had a very direct role
in contributing to this to the security
failures that led to the violence quote
investigators found that the capital was
inadequately defended on January 6 not
because of an intelligence failure but
because of a failure to act on the
intelligence let's let's listen to even
the mainstream media mobs NBC's Lester
Holt report listen to the us
the January 6 committee's final report
was more than 800 pages but some
material did not make the cut including
much of its findings on the failures of
federal law enforcement leading up to
the attack the chief investigator of the
January 6 committee says the government
could have prevented it had law
enforcement agencies acted on the
available intelligence do you believe
the attack on the capitol could have
been successfully repelled I think it
would have been a lot different had law
enforcement taken a more assertive
protective posture people familiar with
the committee's work tell NBC News
members downplayed that finding because
they wanted to keep the focus on former
president Trump
this is why Liz Cheney shouldn't be
ashamed of herself why did Christopher
Ray fail to act what was going on inside
the FBI what were they doing to protect
the capital uh pretty much nothing
capitol police chief's son he was
begging for backup in the days before
and that day alone he requested National
Guard assistance not once but six
separate times he was denied it each and
every time and here's what he said to
this show watch there was a number of
requests I went on January 3rd
requesting the National Guard from Paul
Irving that was the first request for
the for the National Guard I then went
to Mike Stinger who's the Senate
Sergeant arms that intelligence
assessment didn't even indicate the
level of threat that we now know uh
existed the significant threat that was
out there the fact that with these FBI
was tracking 18 domestic
terrorist suspects that were coming to
the Capitol and my intelligence unit on
the fourth fifth and sixth put out
intelligence I was saying low
probability of Civil Disobedience I'll
also keep in mind that leading up to the
sixth then president Trump and His Four
witnesses that have already been
interviewed by me that all back up his
story he ordered the National Guard to
remain available in case something
happened so what was our federal
government doing they knew the building
would be packed with lawmakers and the
vice president of our great country they
knew a huge emotionally charged crowd
would be gathering nearby they knew
based on actionable intelligence that
bad actors and agitators would be
present so what on Earth was the FBI
doing to protect the capital and our
elected officials now if Christopher Ray
gets his way we will never know now this
was the complete farce of the j6
committee with their predetermined
outcome sadly nothing has been done to
prevent this from ever happening again
that's not good we should be protecting
our Capital our our institutions our
elected officials just like we should
have followed through on the 574 riots
in the summer of 2020 none of them were
ever fully investigated the people
responsible for thousands of injured
cops a two dozen dead Americans and
billions in property damage were never
held accountable now of course on the
federal level Democrats they're not
interested in holding the FBI
accountable after vilifying local law
enforcement for years and defund
dismantle Nobel they have now entered
into a warm embrace of the FBI now this
love affair with federal law enforcement
will likely continue as long as the
Washington field office does the
Democratic party's bidding for example
the party that once loved and respected
whistleblowers well now threats uh they
seem to now threaten them take a look
Mr Allen have you ever used Twitter yes
or no
I have utilized Twitter yes okay and is
your account at Marcus
a970-50645 that is absolutely not my
account okay that's not your account
well on December 5th 2022 an account
under the name Marcus Allen r tweeted a
tweet that said well it's not my account
ma'am I you haven't let me finish the
question sir the football player you
haven't let me finish the question on
this and the time is mine on December
5th 2022 an account under the name of
Marcus Allen retweeted a tweet that said
quote Nancy Pelosi staged January 6th
retweet if you agree and quote do you
agree with that statement yes or no
that that is I don't no ma'am that's not
my account at all I have I'm asking
whether you agree with that statement
yes or no can you please rephrase do you
think I'm the general lady has expired
staged January 6th I just want him to
answer no answer I'm just telling your
time's up
do you believe that Nancy do you agree
with the statement that this person
tweeted that Nancy Pelosi staged January
6th yes or no no thank you
it's not his account hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else